you often talk about
blockchain and some of these
concepts of decentralization scalability
security all those kinds of things
but one of the most maybe impactful
exciting things that leverage
the blockchain this kind of ledger idea
of common knowledge is cryptocurrency
so the fight in the financial space so
is there can you say
in the same kind of basic way what is
cryptocurrency in the context of this
common knowledge and
context of the blockchain great
cryptocurrency right is a currency
that is on such a ledger so imagine that
on the ledger right initially you know
that somehow
say you and i are the only owner each
one
let's give it our ourselves a billion uh
each of whatever this unit then i start
up
writing on the ledger i give a hundred
of these units to my sister
you give i give as much to my end and
then
and then now because it's written on
belgium and everybody can see my sister
can give
57 of his units he should receive from
me to somebody else
and so and and that is money and that is
money because
you can see that somebody who
tenders your payment as really the money
there right you don't have any more of a
doubt when you want to sell an item
if i got your check is the check covered
if um
right or do i have the money at the
moment of a transaction
you really see because the ledger is
always upgraded what you see
is what i see what the merchants is you
know where the money so is
the most powerful money system there is
because it is totally transparent and so
you know that you've been paid
and and you know that the money is there
you have not to second guess anything
else
so the the common knowledge applied
there is
you're basically mimicking the same kind
of thing you would get in the physical
space which is
uh if you give a hundred bucks or a
hundred of that thing whatever
of that cryptocurrency to your sister
the actual
transfer is as real as you giving like
a a basket of apples to your sister
because that uh so in the case in the
physical space
the the common knowledge is in the
physics
right of the atoms and then it's digital
space the common knowledge is in this
ledger
and so that transfer holds
the same kind of power but now it's
operating in the digital space
correct
you